[Musique]
nous venons de vivre un voyage en
absurdie où l'on nous réunit pour nous
demander notre avis sur des mesures que
l'on ne connaît pas des hypothèses que
l'on ne connaît pas ça donne
effectivement ce sentiment d'un profil
d'improvisation de panique de manque de
manque d'anticipation
le virus circule en france à une vitesse
que même les prévisions les plus
pessimistes n'avait pas anticipé le
nombre de contaminations rapporté à la
population a doublé en moins de deux
semaines
vous pensez qu'ils allaient nous vous
donner quelques hypothèses il peut être
qu'on voit d'ailleurs sur les chaînes
d'information en fait vous en avril on
apprenait davantage en nous écoutant
nous journalistes qu'en écoutant le
premier ministre ben c'est à dire qu'un
peu à ce stade nous savons que quoi que
nous fassions près de 9000 patients
seront en réanimation à la mi-novembre
soit la quasi totalité des capacités
françaises
nous considérons que le gouvernement n'a
pas tiré les enseignements de la
première vague et surtout n'a rien
planifié c'est pas que moi si de madame
le pen aux socialistes le même sentiment
c'est qu'on a eu la pression de généraux
perdu cette opposition n'est pas
crédible
les oppositions après bon c'est toujours
tellement facile et j'ai été dans ce
rôle de dire voilà ce qu'il fallait
faire une fois que ça s'est produit
bon c'est trop simple vous l'avez fait
oui ce sont des clichés non je parle pas
dans cette période mais vous l'avez bien
antérieur le principe de l'âge un moment
on a une vie antérieure di vita nous on
est en train de privilégier ça et c'est
safari
par contre ils nous préparent à une
pilule qui risque d'être amère quand
même si on venait à être re confiné
c'est signé notre arrêt de mort c'est
certain parce que c'était très difficile
on voit que les aides de l'état
aujourd'hui elle ne suffisait pas il ya
beaucoup de tpe beaucoup de petites
entreprises qui ferment et même des gros
qui sont touchés comme sodexo
puisqu'elle sud 2000 suppressions
d'emplois foulée pas faire un jeu des
lycées vous voulez pas fermer les
magasins dits non essentiels ouais je
veux que l'on n'ait
débat ouvert jusqu'à 21h je pense que la
vie doit continuer avec en se protégeant
faut que vous soyez de force de
proposition parce que vous l'êtes pas
beaucoup mais on l'a été à c'est
totalement faux on me dit que vous
n'avez rien à opposer que vous n'êtes
pas au niveau
jeudi vous pas encore des gens qui
devraient se regarder dans la glace
s'il doit y avoir un confinement général
il faut expliquer pourquoi il est
nécessaire
pourquoi il doit être respecté et vers
quoi il doit aboutir ce qui a peut-être
manqué pour le premier confinement j'ai
décidé qu'il fallait retrouver à partir
de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus
tout le territoire national est concerné
avec des adaptations pour les seuls
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
mais parce que nous avons appris des
événements du printemps ce confinement
sera adapté sur trois points principaux
les écoles resteront ouvertes le travail
pourra continuer les ehpad et les
maisons de retraite pourront être
visités
j'ai très peur je veux vraiment que
j'allais vous respirez donc vous pensez
que vous aimez comme au printemps vous
pourrez sortir de chez vous uniquement
pour travailler vous rendre à un rendez
vous médical pour porter assistance un
proche pour faire vos courses
essentielles ou prendre l'air à
proximité de votre domicile
c'est donc le retour de l'attestation le
virus et s'est installé il va rester
parmi nous longtemps plusieurs années
probablement et c'est la première année
qui va être compliqué donc ça va être
compliqué jusqu'au à la fin du printemps
prochain
l'ensemble de ces mesures doivent donc
entrer en application au plus vite
elles le seront dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi et elles seront appliquées à
minima jusqu'au 1er décembre
on a la chance
d'avoir dévié des équipes médicales
absolument fantastique
il faut pas les yeux fusée je compte sur
chacun d'entre vous je serai là nous
serons là et nous y arriverons
tous ensemble vive la république et vive
la france